hello everyone and welcome to the most
important game of the round uh it's
round nine of the vhs.com grand swiss
fabiana karwana versus salireza firuja
and there's uh quite a lot
on the line here they are playing for
world number three spotless quran is
currently world world number three of
future world number four on the live
ratings they're playing for of course uh
you know getting uh the the
uh best places possible in the
tournament but also for that uh spot in
the candidates tournament for some
reason i mentioned in the previous video
that fabi has a guaranteed entrance in
the candidates tournament because he was
the former world church championship
challenger uh well that's uh true it's
not true for the
upcoming candidates tournament that's
true for the candidates tournament that
they just ended uh so what's happening
in this candidates tournament is that we
will have of course the loser of the
magnus cross and yani punishing match so
either magnus or nipple gets um uh free
entrance into the candidates tournament
we have uh young shisht of duda and
sergey karyakin from the feeder world
cup uh taymor rajab of he's the
feed a wild card because well he had uh
he
uh
stepped back from the previous
candidates tournament so mvl could play
he didn't wanna well you guys know what
happened and we will have two of the
players from this here tournament
followed by two more players uh from the
2022 fiji grand prix so those will be
the eight that will be playing uh so
fabi does not have a guaranteed entrance
fab is fighting here for
an entrance to uh to the candidates
tournament so let's check it out uh and
see what happened here it's quite an
enjoyable game uh so fabi with the white
pieces opens with e4 and uh
now uh goes for c6 he goes for the karo
khan defense
we have d4d5 and now e5 so uh quran uh
going for the same strategy as um
uh
uh furuja had a few few rounds ago uh he
played this against i believe uh
let me just check real quickly i don't
want to deceive you
uh he played this in round uh yeah i
believe round six against shiro yeah he
had it against the alexei shirov
and they they went pretty much for the
same line bishop to f5 uh we have h for
now and now uh h5 not allowing any
further expansion with the g4 uh and now
bishop to d3 offering a trade of dark
square bishops uh of uh light square
bishops with bishop characters queen
captures and now queen to a5 checks so
everything the same as in the game
against shirov uh knight to d2 and now
e6 and here uh if you guys have seen
that one knight to f3 was played by
alexey sheriff but here we have knight
to e2 by fabi uh and now comes knight to
e7 as the light square bishops have been
eliminated from the board this f5 square
will be excellent for uh first knight
and also the pawn here on h5 prevents
this pawn from kicking away the knight
with pawn to g4
and here there are a couple of moves
that have been played in this position
like castle c3 is unknown but the move
fabi place has never been played before
uh and he plays b4 pawn to b4 already on
move 9 and it is as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game uh so what do
you do here well grabbing the pawn would
be extremely dangerous uh for example if
queen captures on b4 we can play rogue
b1 challenge the queen and after the
queen moves now even rook captures on b7
and it really wasn't worth it and now
especially if you capture on a2 then
you're really in trouble bishop to e3
really puts pressure on black's position
but also it kind of traps the queen here
so the queen has no squares
of retreating and after something like
knight to d7 we're gonna play knight the
c1 attack the uh black queen here and
that's pretty much all there is if queen
to a1 we're gonna castle here and now
basically your only idea is knight to f5
you want to pick up this bishop here but
we're just going to play bishop captures
on f8 and now if this is captured now
comes knight c the b3 attacking the
queen and after queen to a3 even rook
captures on d7 and that's it black
resigns here for example if captures
knight c5 check picks up the queen so
just one line to show you how uh
poisonous this b4 pawn is so of course
um alireza does not grab it he plays
queen to a6 offers a queen trade but
fabi doesn't really gain all that much
from this trade as he would simply help
alireza develop so here queen to b3 and
now knight to f5 so the knight gets to
this very nice square we have knight to
f3 now the d4 pawn is sufficiently
defended uh and you can
continue developing but for the moment
white can't really castle because that
queen is still attacking the knight on
e2 so here at knight d7 uh and a4 and
here even though b5 is not a threat uh
just yet uh since the well nothing has
been connected if you play we can simply
capture it the rook would be hanging on
a1 uh alireza goes for queen to c4 now
offers a queen trade here we have bishop
to d2 uh you could trade queens here uh
if fabi trades queens yes he can double
uh spawns here but um it's still a very
very difficult uh position and probably
something else are prepared for example
if you play pawn to c3 then a5 is very
strong for black just going after that b
for pawn so you'd have to play something
like bishop to d2 and then well some
like knight to b6 and if a5 knights to
d5 and black would be very happy with
this position uh so instead after queen
to c4 we have bishop to d2 like we said
and now queen captures on b3 c captures
on b3 and now it is a place f6 uh
challenging this e5 pawn because it's
pretty much the only breakthrough in the
position black can go for at the moment
uh since the c5 square is very nicely
covered by white here and the situation
on the clock is very interesting here
fabi's uh
well some one hour and 20 minutes on the
clock so he spent maybe 10 minutes
alireza is down to 43 minutes
already uh and it's only moved 15 we
have to reach move 40 to gain additional
time so here we have castles uh and now
bishop to e7 uh we have g3 now defending
this pawn so now the knight can move and
the king to f7 by uh already so we have
rook f to e1 and now uh f captures an e5
and this is a very interesting capture
you might also continue with something
like rook a to g8 then maybe something
like
g5 would be very interesting
but the just capturing uh
uh uh for for the sake of captures we we
often say that uh that's not very good
uh and especially here because f
captures an e5 d captures on e5 and uh
now already started thinking so but i've
seen this uh many many times you know
you just capture a pawn because you know
you want that pawn over the board and
then you start thinking for like half an
hour i i've done this in classical games
as well uh so nothing uh you know weird
happening here that's just how chess
players
do things uh so here we have rook 8 c8
now further preparing this c5 push and
it's very interesting now it's uh 25
minutes for alireza and fabi well over
one hour uh and he immediately plays
knight to f4 now it's a very important
move because now uh you're really asking
black what do you do uh the problem is
um black
would want to play something like uh
rook to c7 maybe double up on the c file
maybe push uh c5 there but for the
moment uh this uh knight very nicely
controls this h5 pawn so here we might
see something like rook to c7 and if
rook 8 to c1 g6 defending this pawn
knock for example king g2 rook h to c8
so this is how black
could and maybe even should play this
but alireza plays a very very active and
different line he plays d4
now c5 is coming next he's abandoning
this plan of rook the c7 followed by
rook to c8 and now we have rook a to c1
by fabi now also possible and very
interesting is just a5 here uh because
now if for example c5 you can play b5
and if a6 b6
and you really have something going on
here for example if c4 we can play
characters captures and now rook 8 is c1
and white is better here because of the
undefended pawn on h5 you can't play
rook h to c8 because then you will lose
the pawn at some point and you can't
really defend the rook you can't really
move the rook away from the c file and
allow something like rook to c7 so it'd
be uh your best move is just to give up
the pawn here rook h the c8 we capture
on c four captures and then just the
knight captures on on h5 so that's
something to consider but okay uh we
have rook eight to see one fab is
playing incredibly fast here he also
doesn't want to already
think for free on fabby's time
and now just c5 again uh here alireza
spent a lot of time for this c5 move as
he had a very important move to consider
so after pawn to c5 we did not see b cat
person c5 like one might expect but we
actually saw uh
knight
knight to d5 and this is very
interesting here uh knights the d5 is
played by fabian he played it uh fairly
quickly because uh alireza is down
already to some seven minutes and 40
seconds on the clock uh so what do you
do here uh can you capture this knight
well not really if you play e captures
on d5 it's basically game over then e6
check comes
you play king e8 we win the piece back
king captures on d7 and now knight the
e5 check and the black is just terrible
here uh the problem is if you go
something like king to d8 then we can
play knight to f7 check and win some
material and if you play king the e8
it's not much better we're gonna play
knight to g6 attack the rook and the
bishop here and if something like rook
to h7 trying to preserve preserve
material even bishop g5 put more
pressure on the bishop on e7 and if
something like rook to c7 defending we
can easily capture and after knight
captures even rook captures on c5
because if the rook moves we first
capture an e7 with check and then we
recollect here and if something like
rook to d7 you can even get checkmated
king to f7 uh rook to f8 to check and
now after king after sun g6 even rook to
e6 check checkmate so uh you know it
doesn't uh work out very well for you if
you go for this line after knight to d5
so the knight can't really be captured
uh you could consider something like uh
well maybe king the g6 is very
interesting uh king to g6 is
particularly very interesting
because now you don't really have a good
idea of what to do with
with this knight here because now this
is a threat and you would probably have
to go back and we repeat king to f7 so
maybe if uh something like this happened
then fabi would just go for uh b
captures on c5 and continue playing this
so maybe he was just testing alireza
with knights to d5 uh but either way
after knight to d5 ali is just played c
captures on b4 and now uh what uh what's
happening here well we have king the g6
uh sorry we have first uh knight
captures on e7 knight captures on e7 and
now comes knight the g5 with check uh
you have to
really figure out what to do here you
could capture on b4 you could play
knight to g5 check capturing on d4
is never really an option because if you
capture on d4 then a5 cements this pawn
on b4 and this is this is now okay for
black so your real question is whether
to capture on b4 or to go for this
knight to g5 check capturing on b4 is
very very interesting uh so we're gonna
explore this uh just a little bit as
this is a classical game and when fabi's
playing you have really a lot to
discover the point is after this bishop
captures on b4 and knight to d5 we play
bishop to b6 a bishop to d6 and now we
keep control of the e7 square and the f6
square and now at night the g7 remains a
threat for example if brook the c3 we're
going to play knight g5 check king to g6
and we're gonna capture on e6 and now
after let's say rook h to c8 doubling up
here we're going to play rook c to d1
put pressure on this pawn and after
black defends it we're going to play
rook to d2 now double up on the d file
rook captures on b3 rook e to d1 and
this would be very very good for white
if for example the the other rook comes
and helps out with the defense of the
pawn we can even play knight to d4 and
now chase away this rook next we can
play knight to b5 it would be impossible
to defend this with black
uh so after bishop captures on b4 uh
very good things uh could happen but uh
instead of this fobby went for the
immediate knight the g5 check and it's a
little bit different king to g6 now
comes rook captures on c8 he wants to
get rid of a pair of rooks off the board
rook captures and now knight captures an
e6 and now what do you play here uh well
uh in the game knight the c6 was played
which is a very very important you want
to guard your pawns here
but
other than that you you really don't
have a
better move maybe a5 but then the d4
pawn hangs tonight the c6 really takes
care of both of these ideas uh but now
we have f4 by fabi uh and the really
cool thing is that uh algresa is down to
some six and a half minutes on the clock
so here you also possible is knight to
f4 for example if king to f5 we could
even capture an h5 but now you lose the
uh the e5 pawn so maybe uh fabi's f4 uh
does uh you know uh have a bit more
punch to it so king the f5 now well it
is sacrificing the g7 pawn and this is
uh a really really uh awesome maneuver
by
alireza as it uh really improves the
activity of his king so here we have
knight captures on g7 check and now he
goes back king to g6 you do not want to
go in with something like king to g4
then king g2 and your king will not have
uh will not have a good time here it's
just a really really terrible position
for your king you're going to play f5
we're going to play rook to e4 and
that's it uh so of course the king has
to go back king to g6 and now we have
knight back to e6 uh it is a repeats
king to f5 uh and now if fabi goes
knight to g7 check again then we
probably see some sort of a repetition
here but fabi wants to play for the win
and he plays knight to g5 but this also
activates alireza's pieces as now knight
to c5 so the idea behind the g7 pawn
sacrifice
was to get away uh get this knight away
from the e6 square so the c5 square is
vacated for the black knight
and
it's really interesting because alireza
thought of all of this with some three
minutes on the clock so here we have
knight to f7 now fabi wants to play
knight d6 check and pick up the rook on
c8 so king to e6 and now knight to d6
again attacking the rook uh rook to g8
now going for this pawn on g3
and now king to g2 just defending this
pawn also very interesting here is just
f5 check if you want to throw that in
before for example king d5 and bishop to
f4 you could also defend it like this
but
like i said all it is is below three
minutes on the clock and fabi does not
want to uh give him any time to to think
about the position so king g2 and the
now only now king to d5 uh if you're
wondering why not knight captures on b3
uh well it's a little bit dangerous uh
as this king is still here this just
gives a
white uh free tempe to bulldoze spawns
f5 checking d5 and now uh even knight to
e4 so really uh a crazy position here
and after something like rook to f8 we
can go knight to the f6 check king to c4
and even bishop to h6 uh just getting
that uh rook away from there and now
we're gonna start pushing these pawns uh
it's gonna be
very very hard to stop them so alireza
plays king to d5 first now of course
this is impossible because the e5 pawn
would just fall
so here we have rook to b1 and now the
pawn is defended and now knight to e4
attacking the bishop here
so knight captures an e for king
captures on e4 and rook to c1 now so
already made incredible progress with
his king here uh and he's ready to to
push for more than a draw here we have
king to d3 attacking the bishop and uh
we have bishop to e1 and now even king
the e2
so uh it's very dangerous as this pawn
is now ready to be pushed forward with
e6 fabi pushes his own pawn as that's
the only way to counter this position
and now d3
uh and now the situation on the clock is
fabi has some eight minutes uh whereas
alireza has about 20 seconds on the
clock and it's uh move 37 so three more
moves need to be made in order to
reach time control so here we have f5 uh
defending this pawn now of course we
want to play f6 f7 and so on uh and uh
now the problem is uh you really have to
play a perfect move in order to
uh in order to play this the problem is
if you play d2 white happily sacrifices
the bishop and after this even picks up
the knight and then b captures on c6
we're gonna play f6 and the pawns are
now unstoppable whatever you play
doesn't really matter f7 here we're
going to push this and then we bring a
queen into the game so that's not the
way to make progress here another one
way to make progress here is rook to e8
but uh
you know with few seconds on the clock
this move is incredibly difficult to the
spot uh alireza made this move with some
seven seconds left on the clock he
played knight to d4 and it seems like
it's an incredibly dangerous move
because you go after the f5 pawn and you
can't push this because then you lose
this pawn uh but now the position is
actually winning for fabi or if not
winning uh even you know
really really close to winning it would
be have to be like maybe perfect defense
in order for it not to be winning uh so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this move for an incredible
move for fabi while i give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on figuring out that
if the bishop was not on this square
rook to e1 would be checkmate so
you know taking that into consideration
of course you guys found bishop captures
on v4 and congratulations on that so now
you know that of course the pawn is
never really a target because rook to e1
is checkmate so of course we cannot play
that uh fabi grabbed the b4 pawn and now
alireza has to figure out something else
to play and he has uh you know very very
little time to do so so d2 was played
and now of course bishop captures on d2
fabi sacrifices his bishop king captures
on d2 and uh here it's move 40 we reach
time control and players are given
additional time so now you can rest a
little bit but you still have to be
incredibly precise now you have to
decide between rook to f1 and rook to c5
how do you defend this spawn uh well
rook to f1 is okay but rook the c5 is
better because well you could also bring
the rook to e5 and then you really
control those pawns and this is what
fabi plays
so now can you capture on b3 not really
if you capture on b3 then you have rook
to d5 check and after king to c3 just f6
and if knight's the d4 uh f7 of course
rook f8 e7 and it's game over so uh uh
alireza goes rook to e8 that move that
had to be played before knights to d4
but there simply wasn't time for it so
rook to e5 uh and now
again an excellent excellent position
because uh how do you proceed here with
with black you're up a piece but there
is it doesn't seem to be anything you
can do if you go knight to c6 challenge
the rook we can even play rook to d5
check and after king to e2 just b4 we
know that the knight can never move so
far away because the pawns are just
winning uh so for example a6 but we're
just gonna kick away the knight captures
captures in it after knight to e7 rookie
five check king to d3 and now f6 uh if
knight to g6 we can play even f7 and the
you know it's perfectly fine if rook to
e7
we can capture on h5 and if rook
captures on e6 we can play rook to d5
check king the c4 and now uh even h5
just take away uh this knight from uh
controlling the f8 square and if knight
f8 of course even rook to d8 so
completely winning for white so knight
the c6 does not work uh king to d3 yeah
is what alireza played and now we have
king to f2 now this is again very very
important uh if you wanna uh you know uh
play play it precisely if you over push
it with something like a pawn to e7 then
this is very dangerous knight to c6 rook
to d5 check king e4 and now if f6 uh we
can even play knight captures on e7 uh
so that's uh that's basically the idea
and here white would have to go for
something like rook to d1 to try rook to
e1 check but now just king f5 and after
f captures rook captures we would have
this position where white is up upon but
still with with a much better position
uh so this is what happens if e7 is
pushed but here king to f2 was played
and now uh fabi just goes uh for the uh
very nice uh rook
sorry alireza goes for rook to e7
uh and uh
uh how do you proceed here well now it's
much much different now g4 can be played
uh g4 when when the king was still on
the g file could be a bit dangerous but
now we have h captures on g4 king to g3
and now uh you can't really go for uh
knight captures on f5 here rook captures
and rook captures and e6 because rook f7
and uh white white's position is simply
much much better if a6 we're gonna
capture on b7 there's just no playing
this so after king g3 we have rooked
back to e8 now king captures on g4 we
have knight to c6 attacking fabi's rook
here king to f4 beautiful move bobby
even says okay you're welcome to capture
my rook because then the pawns will be
unstoppable uh so all it is it goes
knight to e7 but now just f6 uh even
allowing this fork because uh fabi no
longer cares about his rook knight the
uh g6 check king to f5 and now of course
we already mentioned that you cannot go
for this so knight captures an h4 check
was played king g5 now knights the f3
check this is uh you know uh the the
maximum number of forks uh you could
have in a chess game and now after king
to f4 we have knight to d4 of course the
rook is still off limits so knight to d4
and now we have e7 now of course f7 is
coming so knight to c6 but now uh even
f7 so the rook again being offered but
there is no point in playing this uh
furuja did not resign here he even
played rook captures on e7 because it
seems like there's a trick in the
position but there really isn't uh the
trick in the position is if uh for
example rook captures an e7 is played
then we can play knight captures on e7
and if f8 queen the knight the g6 check
uh wins back the queen and maybe black
is winning the problem is after this if
we can just play king to g5 and there's
no more uh forking with the knight to
just f8 queen will win the game but fabi
didn't want to mess around after rook
captures on e7 he just played rook to d5
check and he was in this position animal
54 that uh alireza firuja resigned the
game uh and a very very nice victory for
fabiana corona who takes down the leader
and uh
well delivers uh furuja's first loss of
the tournament so now after nine rounds
there are two more rounds to go as there
are 11 rounds in total and we have a
three-way tie at the top it's furuja
fabiana corona and the david howell or
all three on six and a half points uh so
we'll see what happens in the in the
next two rounds we're gonna uh uh cover
one of david's uh uh games as well as he
he's doing incredibly well he he won his
four uh last games in a row so that's
incredibly incredibly impressive
uh so a tough break for alireza it
seemed like he was just gonna steamroll
the entire tournament but uh fabi is a
very very uh tough nut to crack as as
you've seen
uh so yeah that's the game uh sorry
about again being a bit of a longer
video but that's how it usually is when
fabi is playing um so sorry about that
uh i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to chess hassi i would like to
i wish a very happy birthday to pair for
sale and a very happy birthday to busca
uh i hope you guys spent your days uh
very very well with lots of friends and
you know many chess games and i would
like to thank tom darryl and muhammad
ali for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this uh
incredible event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh so thank
y'all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day